Elon Musk is the world's richest man and
he was asked in an interview once would
you rather be a billionaire or a meme
Lord and of course Elon Musk said he'd
rather be a meme Lord now that Meme Lord
activity brought him into the world of
Bitcoin cryptocurrency and he actually
put 1.5 billion dollars of Bitcoin on
the Tesla balance sheet about a year and
a half ago in the summer of last year
they sold 10 of that Bitcoin at a profit
and they said that they were simply
trying to test the market liquidity and
so they had somewhere around 1.2 to 1.3
billion dollars of Bitcoin but in their
most recent Financial disclosures they
went ahead and reported that they sold
75 of their Bitcoin position that's 75
sale netted them about 936 million
dollars onto their balance sheet now you
may remember last July Elon talked about
cryptocurrency and here's what he said I
made pump but I definitely don't dump I
do not believe in getting the price high
and selling or anything like that I
would like to see Bitcoin succeed now
that leads to the question why exactly
is Tesla selling 75 of their Bitcoin
well it's because they needed the cash
elon's quoted as saying that their sale
should not be taken to some verdict on
bitcoin instead Tesla sold his Bitcoin
because it was concerned about overall
liquidity of the company giving covet
shutdowns in China and that they needed
the cash he also states that they did
not sell any of their Dogecoin and he
believes that crypto is a sideshow to
the sideshow now my takeaway from all of
this is that elon's running a business
they need to have a strong balance sheet
they need to have cash flow that's what
he's focused on doing their investment
in Bitcoin he rode the wave he created
plenty of press the critics hated it and
in some way he was sticking it to the
Man by being one of the first public
companies to put Bitcoin on their
balance sheet but the more interesting
takeaway from the recent developments of
this sale is that the market basically
didn't care when they announced that
they had sold 75 percent of their
Bitcoin the market went down like a one
percent or so they literally just did
not care at all that the world's richest
man and one of the largest companies in
the world sold 75 of their Bitcoin
that's because the market is maturing
the impact by one individual or one
company is lessening day by day and
ultimately a more mature Market is
exactly what we should want to see we
don't want to have a market their
response very sensitively to any one
announcement from a business or an
individual instead what you want is a
robust Market structure with deep
liquidity where anyone in the world can
participate and not have to worry about
what's the next press release ready to
drop ultimately Elon Musk he still owns
a ton of Bitcoin SpaceX balance sheet
and personally he also has about 200
million dollars of Bitcoin on the Tesla
balance sheet I think they just needed
the cash and that's okay because in some
ways Bitcoin served as a great store of
value they lost a little bit maybe five
seven eight percent on the Bitcoin
position but if you take into account
inflation in some way Bitcoin actually
held more value over the last 12 months
than cashed it now that's not something
that you'll hear in the mainstream media
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time